so here's zach kepler who's coming off a
six-inning performance against the mets
and jacob degrom where he did out pitch
the best pitcher in baseball
but the phillies wound up losing that
ball game it's been part of this run
of a struggling bullpen moments and
defensive moments as well
popped up right side not deep
segora's there so is harper
one out here in the first south philly
cheer for fernando
who will be starting the all-star game
of course a ground ball
and kicks off of gregorius into left
field the philly
infield defense has not been good this
year in fact by some metrics alec baum
is the worst third baseman in all of
baseball dd just his second game off the
il
and here's manny a dozen homers 50
stakes and a 259 average so far for
machado
and manny hits that one a ton out to
straight away center double herrera
going back and it's into the forest
off effluent effluents forest it's
amazing to me when you watch manny
machado swing the bat
it's almost like he feels for he doesn't
really attack the ball kind of feels for
it
two to nothing padres in the first
number 13
for number 13. 34 year old veteran
right-hander making his 17th start
career against the phillies a really
good era at 1.42
last two times out six innings that is a
curveball and
strike three gene sigur will now dig in
for the phillies
and try to lay off he did not
back-to-back case to start the bottom of
the first inning for you darvish
so two walks in an inning which is a
rarity to
even have two walks in a game for zach
keflan here's darvish
swinging a miss healthy hack first
strikeout for effluent
fam who popped out to right his first
time up ground ball left side dede's got
it he surrounded it
throws on the run in time and the side
is retired
no runs no hits there were two left two
walks by effluent
so bryce harper leaves it off harper
yesterday over four with an rvi
a towering fly ball to deep right field
myers going back and it is
gone first row of the second deck a solo
home run for bryce to start the second
it's a 2-1 game you know what manny
you're going to go
top i'll go up top with you hang time on
that had to be what
15 seconds oh my goodness how to bring
up rhys hoskins
reese 221 hitter with 17 home runs
that one's drilled deep to left field
this game is tied
up solo home run for reese
his 18th of the year he's got to make
sure he touches
first it's a 2-2 game
how about it first pitch fastball
hunting
rosaries hoskins as well as grace harper
that's how you ambush
you darvish that was a rocket wasn't it
sure was
brings up jake cronin worth out to
center field it's not deep
oh doable started back now he's in and
he's there for the second half maddie
machado is the hitter
popped it up real muto
behind home plate perfect technique a
one two three third inning
ten pitch inning for zach eflin oh dubo
herrera to lead things off for the
phillies here in the bottom of the third
inning
got him udarvish strikes out odubal
herrera for the second time
this afternoon gene segura will now step
in the right-hand batters box
and he gets him again here in the third
back-to-back case and now five on the
day for you
so here's will myers myers trying to bun
his way on his first time up
ground ball in the second that should be
two there's one
and two in time to get myers
4-6-3 double play udarvish will go out
for his fourth inning
of work and he's going to face that same
part of the order that gave him problems
in the second inning
this round goes to darvish as he makes
harper look bad
and now six strikeouts for you one out
walk issued to andrew mccutchen that'll
bring up
reese hopkins hoskins who had a home run
back in the second inning
and strikes out this time darvish blows
him away with a 96 mile an hour heater
windows pick it up a little bit with
foul into the on deck
circle by alec bowm here we go they're
gonna put the tarp on the field
chrisguccione waited as long as he could
this is a middle of an at-bat for dede
he's not happy about that
or should he be i thought maybe they
would at least try to finish the at-bat
yeah that would make way too much sense
i mean i get it it's raining
all right here we go we're going to
resume play 8
11 in the evening in the east and now
with two down
the count is no balls and two strikes to
dede gregorius
has that one caught by cronenworth and
finally the bottom of the fourth inning
comes to a close
zach f1 had a pretty quick fifth inning
and he's back out there here in the
sixth
swing and a miss through the curveball
one out only the second strikeout for
effluent
and bring up manny machado who is the
only real blemish today for
zach eflin the home run by machado in
the first
bouncer back to the mound knocked down
by f what he's got time
throws off his back leg what a pick by
hoskins
foot is on the back side is retired
that's a nice job all the way around
here comes j.t romuto who's over two
that one's out toward right it's pretty
well hit meyers going back toward the
scoreboard it is off the top of the
scoreboard and he kicks it away
jt's around second heading to third the
throw by myers is
not in time and the phillies with a go
ahead base runner 90 feet away and bryce
harper coming up with one out here in
the sixth
and harper lines one out toward right
field myers is there
he'll make the catch jt's tagging the
throw to the plate
is up the line the phillies take the
lead
count still full to reece hoskins cronin
worth trying to keep mccutchen honest at
second
liner out to left field that's going to
be it for a base hit mccutchen's going
to
stroll home easily hoskins on his way to
second he'll get there rbi
double two ribbies today reese
phillies are on top four to two eighth
pitch of that at bat
it's another breaking ball to his liking
and lace it down the left field line
grisham is aboard to start things here
in the seventh
left side nice play there's one over to
first in time
a laser from segora here's will myers
4-2 ball game
swinging a miss 92 side is retired here
in the seventh
two down now here's gene segura first
pitch swing right field it is going to
be
fair into the corner for extra bases
jerks and profar is going to run it down
meanwhile alec baum is going to be sent
home here comes the throw he is
safe at the plate they may check that
one caratini on the swipe tag it was
pretty close on the relay
looks like they're going to challenge
this foot comes up he never touched home
plate
right there he does but does caratini
make contact that's what we're trying to
figure out yeah that's the question yeah
because if he did then i think he's out
but it's whether or not
he did and if we can see that he
certainly did oh i think he did on the
arm
i do too yeah they're gonna ring him
they say that the tag was made on the
throw by cronin worth of victorini on
the swipe tag
brings up the right theater jerickson
profar
off the hands out toward the middle
diving catch dede gregorius whoa
what a play the reactions around the
infield were
unbelievable after he made that catch
from reece hoskins to gene segora who
was jumping up and down
as if he got a new bicycle from our
vantage point i don't think he had a
chance to get to this ball
well manny machado will be the last hope
popped up
left side this should do it alec foam is
there
it does do it the phillies have won the
series against the padres
they win it today four to two yes it was
a
clean ninth inning